JENNY BROWN: Today we're
talking about Next '21 data loss
protection and Google
Distributed Cloud.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud Next '21 is
over, but the learning
is just beginning.
With three days of keynotes,
deep dives, and announcements,
there was a lot to take in.
But don't worry if
you missed something.
The Google Cloud
blog team is here
to round up our
favorite announcements.
Check out the blog for more.
Data is one of your
most valuable assets,
so we're happy to
announce that we're
making Cloud DLP automatic--
automatic discovery,
automatic inspection, automatic
classification, automatic data
profiling.
Now available in
preview for BigQuery,
you can enable Cloud DLP
across your entire organization
to gain visibility
into your data risk.
Organizations are looking
to accelerate their cloud
adoption.
However, some of their workloads
can't move to the public cloud
entirely or right away, due
to a variety of factors.
To ensure these
workloads can still
take advantage of what
the cloud has to offer,
we announced Google
Distributed Cloud,
a portfolio of
solutions consisting
of hardware and software that
extend your infrastructure
to the edge and into
your data centers.
Check out the full
details on the blog.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.